foreign
[Music]
cast number 20. today we are joined by
uh Robert Graham who ran Recon missions
out of ccs and as we get started again
we always thank Jocko willing
productions for making these saw casts
possible and today is sawcast 20. Rob
welcome to the show thank you and uh
your unique history here with us because
we've only had one other CCS Recon
Hatchet Force man and Marcus Witt and uh
so glad you joined us in your history is
kind of unique because you're one of the
few Canadians who left Canada to come
fight with special forces and then you
ended up in saug so how will that start
for you uh well I was kind of a lost
soul I was hitchhiking around Canada and
and
um ended up I ended up actually joining
the circus in uh Calgary traveled with
them for until they went back into the
US and they wouldn't let me in the US
so I ended up buying a a 59 Karmann Ghia
and I drove down to Acapulco
hustled there because
in the circus being a barker and doing
what he's doing on the circus I learned
how to hustle pretty well and so I was
living down in Acapulco for a while and
living off the Canadian uh Navy sailors
would come in that's was their RNR Place
sure and uh so I made a little living
there and stayed there for about a year
I guess thereabouts excuse me and
decided well I better head back up to
Canada head back up to Canada and I was
traveling with a guy who had just gotten
out of the army
and man that sounds pretty interesting
so I stopped off at Buffalo and went
into the post office went into the
Marines thing there and I said uh I want
to join the Marine Corps I want to go to
Vietnam and he goes oh that's you know
yeah outstanding he said but uh and I
said I'm from Canada and you know oh
sorry we we don't take Canadians uh and
there's a bunch of reasons why but we
don't take Canadians and I went oh man I
already had Mark said on doing this sort
of thing and he said why don't you go
down the hall the army takes anybody
[Laughter]
so I did I went down the Army and signed
it and they did yep I signed up uh they
said well what do you want because you
could pick your MOS more or less I guess
volunteer yeah and I said well I want to
be that guy and it was the that Robin
Moore poster and all that you know and
he said well I can't do that but we can
get you um Airborne airborne and uh
infantry yeah okay let's do that so I
did my you know Fort decks and AIT you
know Benning and ended up at bragan
training group excuse me
in a training group and they ended up
going through Carmel
so back then they had to go through code
school so the first part of comos I'm
doing the old stuff yeah and I pass uh
the code
schools per minute yeah so I got that
and then uh the other Canadian and I
pulled us aside and I said well we can't
let you go any further and come home
because uh you don't have clearance
because from now on it's codes and codes
and sure and the CAC pad one-time pads
and radios and stuff oh man that makes
no sense at all so uh I they ended up
putting me in on I so so I went through
all when I uh anyway graduated I guess
there's probably about oh and I as the
operation Intel price yeah that's more
printing yeah you know interrogating and
just what a trip uh so went through the
Oni course uh
got the 15 about 15 of us were
graduating if I remember right and
almost all of us went to fifth group
went to Vietnam
excuse me landed in the trang and what
time frame here Bob
I'm guessing a March March 69 bookmarks
69. and um
and so we're sitting on the guys sitting
on the on the bunker watching you know
the minigun never seen a minigun fire
before at night which is cool yeah very
cool and the guy says and the guy says
well you've all volunteered for the CNC
projects so uh you know oh thank you did
you know you volatile no you're all
volunteers for CNC and so they split us
up I went to South and the other fellas
went to you know uh Central and North we
arrive at uh at Miami to it and they
said um well were you thanks for being
here you're volunteered for Recon
company that's outstanding and so I
ended up Recon company and got assigned
to team pick right away and stayed with
Team pick for a year and a half a year
and a half yeah yeah like I said I only
ran two operations with other teams
because they needed me and I but
everything else was team pick wow yeah
so that's quick for it because that's
the difference you didn't get the chance
to volunteer you had already volunteered
on be nice to yourself how many times
you volunteered to get through to that
far I mean for the Army for Airborne for
SF for everything you know but yeah oh
yeah I volunteered man love it so yeah
so welcome to bambitour at CCS yeah
indeed and so um who was the CEO at the
time was Curly still down there
I kind of lose track I know is that
happen to her is currently the same as
hecklinger I'm not sure of God I'm
drawing a black we call him curly so
anyways you curly was there sure was was
there
um we went through a bunch of sergeant
majors Billy wa
was there uh Brock
uh was there and the other sergeant
major was the fella that
oh gosh
and he's the guy that went from Bangkok
and tried to sneak into uh and got him
got murdered he tried to
sneak into uh Laos to try to rescue pows
oh and and he got murdered and they
found his body and they brought his body
back on damn I'll think of his name Mata
Morris was also Sergeant Maynard okay
and so you get on RT pick RT pick the
team leader was uh Fred Winters and uh
Everett Coffer was the 1-1 and I was the
one two
so so what was Alexa was that a yard
team yeah no yeah okay all right
yeah yeah and uh how was that coming in
from Canada welcome to uh RT pick and
you're dealing with money yards
well I'd uh not not really really wasn't
new to me I'd been my dad's career
military okay and lived overseas and he
was in the Diplomatic course so he's a
military attache and so I'd lived in New
Delhi India and oh in you know various
places you've been around the world yeah
so I mean it's pretty good dealing with
with locals certainly yeah that was
another skill set that helps yeah yeah
absolutely yeah used it all up until I
retired uh two years ago
so very good so you're on you're on a
team and uh so initially how much
individual training because you're the
new guy on a team they break you in or
did you find yourself running ambition
pretty quick right away yeah and and in
fact I was a radio guy
and so I said hey uh I really don't know
anything about radios because I wasn't
allowed because of the security
clearance so I don't know anything about
these secret pads and one that's I think
they called them one time pad yeah right
the cat codes cat codes yeah and Fred
Winters ah [__] that's [__] come
here let me show you yeah so here's your
radio there's here you've never used
Morse code again you've never used Morse
code again here's your radio the prick
25 right and uh and uh and uh here's the
pad and you know so yeah and we were in
the field real quick and then we came
back I really don't remember anything
about the operation but and I don't
think we even got in contact but we came
back and we might have but I I can't
remember yeah but anyway Fred quit and
said I don't want to do this anymore a
lot of guys do that as you know oh yeah
I don't want to do that so he went down
the Quan Lloyd down the launch site and
so Everett took over and I became the
1-1 one mission one one right up yeah
yeah it's the promotion instant
promotion you spend a lot of money from
your pay raise yeah yeah really I did
buy a Rolex you did yeah
well that's our SF a lot of the SF guys
had to Rolexes and then the uh Ring The
Ring gotta have the start Sapphire I
didn't get that either yeah and we got
our seikos so I'm cheap the Seiko you
know self-wound you could read it at
night yeah it's a better watch than
Rolex there's nothing all it is it's
flashy and it sure as hell doesn't tell
time well
it may maybe they're better now but uh
yeah maybe yeah so
um moving right along because you had
some missions that as time unfolded they
were historic in nature from some of the
odds you came up against and
um as you move forward
um you see you get used to the base your
team is good and uh so Everett was the
one zero yes and uh how'd it go from
there so what was the first mission
where you like in my case I had four
missions including a couple in-country
things just as practice missions where
no CIB or nothing because there's no
enemy fire of consequence
and so you're missing your first mission
you didn't get fired up right yeah I
know that I think that but uh after that
you know I ran over 60 different
operations uh or you kept track of that
you had that many I lost track but I
know it was over 60 and I was over 30 as
a 1-0 really yep
um and I said uh I started keeping track
and I don't know why but I just happened
to remember it's over 30 and it was over
60 total maybe you had to do it for your
air medals you had to keep track of
going across some [__] metal didn't
it I mean it really is all you got to do
is fly 25 times you get an air medal you
know yeah but you got it documented I've
never had to keep my flight long yeah I
got I got a couple of those yeah um and
then um but I I would say of all the
times
I can't remember any time
maybe once or twice where we did not get
in contact sure you know we were in
contact always all the time and usually
uh right off the LZ oh is that right
lots of times right off the Aussie got
in contact in fact one of the big
lessons Lessons Learned you know because
you you don't learn this stuff back at
the base or whatever right
I got off the uh the LZ and and waited
and made sure everything was kind of
cool Choppers left walked off the LC
didn't go but
25 yards and and didn't make contact but
the the point guy and then somebody over
there started yelling at each other so
we knew we and we could tell okay
something's going on here and uh and so
then there was some firing going on
between the appointment and the other
bad guy and so we all turned around uh
contact
to the chopper get them back in because
they hadn't been gone you know that
right before
Lessons Learned I'm going to have my
antenna tucked down right
so I'm gonna pop the antenna up we're
all running back the same trail that we
came down from the uh LZ and so they had
set up a hasty ambush let the team
leader go
let the The Interpreter go let the team
leader go another end did and me and I
came up and I got shot no yeah he waited
that guy waited for the radio guy
they're a pretty smart dude oh yeah
waited for the radio guy I got shot
right here but it hit the
um bolt assist on my car no yeah and it
picked me up uh you know threw me off to
the side and uh and Coffer yeah the last
two behind me and he goes uh he says
pick up Graham he's been shot and and I
do my as I've done several times you do
fingers and toes yeah oh yeah okay okay
okay and I'm still alive I'm thinking
therefore I'm alive yeah so I rolled
over
started to shoot in only one round it
was already in the chamber one round and
went with that and I tried oh that's
when I saw it yeah and so I just threw
it over my shoulder and the only thing I
had was a little Browning at least you
had a brown yeah but with a little 25
best pack that's what I call it this
pocket yeah little little teeny Browning
oh about 25. oh 25 yeah yeah you could
hide it in the palm of your hands yeah
exactly that's all it is 25 caliber yeah
and so uh we ran back we and I you know
fired a big deal run back up in the
chopper and get on there and the door
gunner is going what the hell with a
pistol I need the damn thing
I showed him yeah and he went home
you can see his mouth moving and uh off
we went you know yeah so
but that was Lessons Learned
well and learned we did you know all
kinds of stuff you do oh man okay yeah
and I'm alive but now I know I won't do
that again you know kind of thing indeed
yeah and so you and uh
Bill DC
and uh trying to think who else
you're the third guy that I know that
got hit with the car 15.
I got hit again
um with the car 15 yep yep uh twice yeah
hit the front sight
of my weapon yeah and it shattered from
here opened my nose up open up that's
where this all kind of open all that up
and it passes the shrapnel all the way
from here down to here and there's a lot
of it still in there no kidding yeah
when I go to the dentist and they do
X-rays I gotta tell them uh no no they
say something's wrong with the machine
no no no no now I just tell them look
you're going to see there's a lot of
shrapnel in here I'm metallic yeah
oh my God it goes off you go through
this is it enough at the airport no you
can turn that sensitivity up on them
okay with the wands yeah yeah you can
play that but I don't know if it's
fillings or metal or whatever you know
so but there's I had to um uh I couldn't
shave because the pieces kept coming out
for years so you had to use an electric
razor yeah
um and now I could shave it's all
nothing really coming out the last piece
that came out was at the tip of my nose
and uh when I went over to VA who I got
to give a lot of respect to VA nowadays
yes back in the day they weren't so hot
no but uh uh if you had to get off the
first floor because the first floor were
the drugs the druggies and the wine
holes and all that kind of stuff but the
doctor took a look at me and and uh at
my nose and there were the it was a
school a VA has a with a medical school
at the University yes they got a lot of
the setup like that Wilmington in
Wilmington Delaware okay sure and uh he
saw this Sisty Boyle [__] looking thing
and he he they put me in the hospital
immediately and they said we have to fix
that because we can't put plastic
surgery on that it's it's going to screw
your nose up kind of whatever right yeah
and so they opened it up did something
they took the piece out it wasn't metal
it was a piece of wood
and uh which is kind of strange you know
I mean I know when I got you know when I
got shot there and I rolled over and
maybe I got in the dirt maybe there's
some kind of wood or I don't know but so
this is the first time you got shot in
your car 15 or a second time your car
you and your car 15 got shot it was both
times both shot here with with the one
car 15 on the volt assist and it was it
was a that was actually not even on my
team that was the second operation I ran
without my my team this was with um
your strap hanging a strap hanging with
pop Taylor and he was on a team Mala and
I I was on stand down because I was
going I was going to go to uh Australia
on r r and I was really looking forward
to that and he said well look this is
we're only going to be there for maybe a
day or two that's gonna be a hot one but
I could use an extra person and so I
need no responsibilities Just Guns and
Ammo
and I said okay you know I'll I'll come
with you and and so I always carried my
thought off 70 m79 and I had a vest with
25 rounds in it plus I just a whole
boatload of ammo and oh my car and uh so
we were going through the this um
flat grassy land which is man that was
nice instead of you know again the up
and down
and we saw them and they saw us at the
same time and they were coming up this
High Speed trailer a trail and there's
three of them
never forget it they both had they all
had the best helmet regular NVA heavy
heavy looking rucksacks
the guy in the front and the guy in the
back had rpds you know like the m60s of
course yeah both of them rpds and the
officer who I assume was an officer in
the center had an AK and they stopped
and we stopped and we got down and they
got down and and I could see the officer
so I went behind this tree and I had it
my you know had it braced up so I could
sure hold it steady and I was just
squeezing that round off when I got hit
right there like pal hit that front side
of my weapon no yeah and bounced me back
and
I think that was a short Mission all
right that was that one there's two cars
oh my God I got a picture of the one uh
of the front sight and I didn't take a
picture of the bolt assist which and I
know these DC has it yeah he got hit
with Bill Downer with you of course you
know he was an air traffic controller
yes of course yeah after after Vietnam
yeah he's a traffic control up in New
York City or in Jersey area yeah yeah
that's right I think he was there even
for 9 11 wasn't he or was he there for 9
11. no I forgot to ask him about that
yeah I haven't seen bill in a few years
boys he is wrapped tight you know yeah
be an air traffic controller I said wow
I love him to death well and just for
our listening audience
um when Bill's story on that the History
Channel had a production called suicide
missions and then they changed the title
to
um dangerous missions to be PC because
suicide after 9 11 just didn't sound
nice and the History Channel changed the
title but more importantly Bill's story
was he's getting extracted and then the
helicopter gets shot down and lands on
him and he survived a helicopter landing
on him I mean actually getting shot down
yeah and uh
um then
um when he gets uh they finally get
pulled out the uh on ropes
the door gunner had an automatic and
they were just holding Bill all the way
back
and it's like oh man one of those crazy
stories but you know not many guys like
you get your car 15 shot twice yeah and
build one of those few that had a
helicopter shot down and lands right on
top of it but somehow he survived it all
that's amazing yes and there's no reason
for it yeah no Rhyme or reasons lucky I
don't know either it's your time or it's
not yeah that's right so um as you as
you're going on with the you get back to
your team so was there any time to rehab
you had to get sewed up the Medics took
good care of you did they actually send
you to a hospital they sent me to uh
flew me to Cameron Bay and so I was at
the hospital at Cameron Bay yeah and uh
I woke I like members I was on the table
and I opened my eyes a big spot late and
I figured man it's like a heaven you
know like you know you died and gone to
heaven and uh not exaggerating the
doctor's heads came in and then I saw
the two doctors come in and one guy went
like that no oh man I thought oh man I'm
not pretty anymore yeah you know and uh
he says well he said what kind of nose
do you want and I said I just want my
nose back and he said well I don't know
what kind you had so I'm going to give
you a little ski jump
so no they packed um
gauze up inside and then sewed me up and
I was there for
uh I guess I was there for about a week
and then they wanted to send me back
because if you get a head wound you
automatically go back to the States was
that right yeah and I said uh I said oh
yeah okay yeah whatever and they were
pulling the this guy oh that was heard
of the painful because it's crusting it
all certified inside but they're pulling
the gauze out and I've gone through this
operation several times since so they
don't use gauze anymore it's a little
plastic insert that they can you know
make it work but anyway I kind of looked
around and I packed up all whatever I
needed to pack up and uh man I don't
know how I managed but I got a chopper
ride back to bammy to it and because
instead of going back to the States no
way I was heading back to Recon so it
went back to bammy to it and um
you know they uh Recon the company
Commander kind of said hey Graham's
Graham's back so uh Lisa Graham's coming
back so I must have gotten in touch with
him to get a flight backer somehow yeah
anyway he went to the Recon guy said
listen he's his face is busted a pretty
bad bin don't make fun of him all right
let's just treat them okay because we
know what a sensitive guy you are and he
and so they all started laughing at me
in the course of course so anyway yeah
that's so yeah it's interesting I forgot
about these yeah yeah indeed so you get
back you heal up a little bit more and
then when's the next time you find
yourself on the ground with the RT pick
um I don't know how long it would take
me to because I was pretty well patched
up it wasn't that I mean this you know
this is all sewed and this is still got
some scar I grew a mustache because I
had the powder powder burns from when my
weapon got hit I guess it must have
fired or something because there was a
brown black uh like a tattoo mark on my
upper lip that's why I grew a mustache
but I I was back out pretty quick I mean
uh
so the next mission you went out and did
not get you and your car 15 shot correct
yeah this one I probably ended up
getting in contact but uh in it was just
another one I don't know what we were
doing indeed you know we did wire Taps
and Trail watches and Road watches and
bomb damage assessments and stuff no
kidding he did the whole so talk a
little bit about
um training up getting ready for your
first wiretap did you have the basic
cassette unit yeah what did you have for
your wiretap equipment or because you're
still the one one yeah and one zero he
had the one zero had had all the wiretap
equipment and I don't I don't remember
other than it wasn't very big right it
was like remember the cassette players
back in our day yeah it was like like
cassette players we had and I trained up
our digital and said tap that phone and
they took care of the rest
telephone poles faster than the
Vietnamese could yeah yeah indeed these
were Ground ours was a a landline really
yeah what was that like there's a big
piece of telephone cable I guess it was
telephone cable that's what yeah that's
what he was tapping
um and I think like the fella was saying
yesterday if I remember it didn't take
very long for them to find out that what
we were doing and uh and so we didn't
stay there very long we probably got
shot out again you know indeed yeah but
at least you did it and then you went
back you turned the cassette over at
some point spooking spook ink would pick
it up and you would never hear another
word nope yep everything thank you yeah
I'm gonna take her back to Saigon and
that was it
yeah oh my God so uh you did a few wire
Taps just one and then um
what was your first BDA like bomb I did
one I did one and it scared the crap out
of me I believe but just for our
listening audience is that a bomb damage
assessment is a special mission for us
after a B-52 strike and Source the Air
Force and His Infinite Wisdom said look
we're going to do a B-52 strike it's an
arc light and we like you guys to go and
take some pictures just show us how you
know assess the bomb damage and so it's
not a problem there'll be Dazed and
Confused nobody's gonna bother you guys
go and take some pictures and come on
back maybe you can have a picnic while
you're out there and then come on back
but the reality of being on the ground
was you found what
well uh nighttime
really nighttime and I'm in the Ron and
uh you know we we undo our boots and
that was it lean back on your rock and
uh and make everybody takes turns doing
the thing
and uh I woke up and I I was kind of
dozing off and I woke up in the air off
the ground like that and Bam like this
and then what the hell and then I could
hear them people don't realize but you
hear the bomb just like in the movies
you know whistle yeah
you can you know multiple times and boom
boom boom boom boom and we were if I
remember correctly I thought we were a
thousand I mean a click away a thousand
thousand meters away right which is
pretty damn close pretty damn close
probably too close
if you wake up in the middle of the year
but but wait a minute the bomb damaged
assessments pulls a captain after they
bomb yeah you guys get inserted before
they bomb that is correct yep oh that's
correct I've never talked to anybody
that's been flying through the air
courtesy of an arc like yeah what the
hell that feel like that's why those
guys that Republican National Guard you
see them all surrendering after the beef
I understand fully
you would not want to go through that no
but when it hits in in the jungle
when the bomb hits and it creates a a
perfect uh bunker situation to hide you
know hunker down in attack but getting
to it is is impossible because all the
trees that were here are now laying down
flat as an outward spikes right and as
you go further out from that Circle they
get they start standing up more and more
and more but to get through from where
they're standing up into that area it
takes a if you need to go there right um
so you usually end up going around
because you know what it is but uh they
don't last very long because the bad
guys have sent in their folks to find a
to rescue who's been shot
and uh so we got shot out of that one
pretty quick and we I mean we went
towards that first thing and uh and got
I can't I can't remember how it all
happened but we got in contact again and
uh and be aded and back and got pulled
out I don't know whether we got pulled
out by strengths that time or not yeah
as the majority of the times you're down
to you uh we had the uh 20th uh Special
Operations Squadron the green hornets
the Air Force and then you had the 195th
and uh yeah with Don Hassey and his boys
and uh
so those are your main units that you
had supporting you at that time yes
that's it we had um the 20th SOS loved
them like brothers oh we all hung out
together uh didn't hang out with the
195th guys that I remember in Quan Loy
uh because quantity was just a launch
site sure more or less you know not a
launch site to go out to the A Team to
launch right but it's it and they had
their own thing and they didn't really
hang out with us
I for no particular reason they may not
have been able to get into our little
compound right right in Quantum line
with a big base compound or air base
area yeah I'm not familiar with that so
that's where your launch site was that
for CCS one of them yeah sometimes well
inside the Quan Lloyd was our little
concertina area right that uh and I
don't they probably couldn't get in sure
it wouldn't be allowed but that was one
of the and it's not it's like a
pre-launch site I guess okay I don't
remember actually launching out of
guanoi but you get to Conroy and then
they you chop her out to an A-Team
somewhere budap boo praying or whatever
oh you're with the boot up we were there
yeah we lost that life would be six and
I don't know some that might have been
the one up North but there's all the a
teams that are strong in that area were
places that we would launch out of and
you know like well that's not all about
you but we learned later that budop had
been closely almost overrun and that a
camp had all kind of you know we just
flew in there because the 20th was there
yeah and we had Thanksgiving dinner with
them in 68 after a mission
and uh years later we learned that boot
up was really highly contested do you
ever get any extra peripheral action
like that no but so straight in and then
you launched from one of the a sites
yeah we'd launched from the age oh no
kidding yeah they were that close yeah
you know so yeah we'd launched and go in
I would I mean 30 miles yeah yeah about
right I don't know but the interesting
thing or the the thing about us as you
know uh the U.S government had made a uh
an agreement with with um cnook I guess
he was the head of Cambodia at the time
allowing no there was no aircraft no no
no fixed Wing nothing was allowed except
Choppers in a small Recon team and that
was it
and so we we didn't have assets I mean
other than the Choppers and of course
the 20th had those miniguns yeah when
they worked yeah yeah well they were
kind of new
you know it's like the old uh
M72 law you know oh yeah someone ain't
worked they're pretty good they were
yeah when they were when they work the
people at the langvay at the February 68
when they got overrun they learned that
uh
many of them didn't work yeah and and
they figured out why later but it's like
apparently they came in with the
shipment and they dropped them
and so it disconnected the key
connectors so a lot of the laws didn't
fire yeah you have just a tank in your
site yeah click yeah bunker click click
yeah there it is oh my God yeah but uh
um
I get off point there a little bit so so
you lost yes indeed and we know we had
uh
we used the
um the green hornets and their minigun
worked perfectly for us unfortunately
that time so you had times when that was
an issue where they'd be come flying in
and all of a sudden all you hear would
be the click yeah yeah
um
but I I guess I can and it may not have
been the green hornets it might have
been the 195th that had did they have
mini guns down there yeah yeah and maybe
theirs didn't work I can't remember
could have been either one but there was
there had to be at the moment in time
where you're on the ground you're in
contact you asked for a gun run you
didn't get it and so meanwhile your team
is there fighting on so how many how big
was your team when you usually ran would
it be a six eight man or no I try to go
with five five yeah two uh me and one
other American right in my three yards
okay because that was and we were all
pretty tight pretty you know we we'll
tell you yeah real tight had a good team
really a good team and sometimes we go
with a bigger team if it needed or I'd
take an extra American if he's brand new
and he's going to be a new guy on my
team so I take him so he could learn
right and uh
you know honestly with you half the time
you ran that one operation and quit
because I ain't doing this anymore
and it was all as you know you could
quit oh yes volunteer that was seriously
a volunteer and you didn't want somebody
on the ground like when Lynn black came
up against is one one was prayed
throughout the entire Mission never
fired around an anger yeah and you don't
want that no no no you gotta have guys
that are able to work the car that's it
man so what was your basic uh um with
only five men what was your basic
loading you carried for your web gear
weapons my start off 79 had 20 I think
it's 24 20 it's either 23 for some
reason or 24 rounds probably 24. okay
and I'd take um depending on the
operation uh I take he
and uh probably about half he and half
fleshets which I don't think the issue
anymore really yeah I think I mentioned
it to one guy and he says yeah we
outlawed them or something and they have
one CS for good luck
um Keith had to break contact
could have been I I can't remember we
had um but 24 rounds yeah 24 rounds on
my uh sawed off m79 indeed yeah and
probably for your car 15 you had
um
thinking 400 okay but that's a heavy
load oh yeah it might have been a little
bit less but I I always went heavy on
ammo and you always carried your 25
Browning with you no okay no I was a
[__] I gave it to someone okay I got
rid of that my actually the only I
didn't have anything else I oh my
sidearm was my sawed-off m79 sure so
when you're just uh moving on routine
Patrol you would have like a set round
an error or something like that probably
yeah probably yeah and then um and my
first magazine like you said yesterday
was all Tracer really I didn't think
anybody else did that yeah it was pretty
interesting it's like it's like aiming
the mag light oh yeah you know like
you're right there you're not missing
you know and if you shoot it down and
you can watch it walk up to them and
they see it you know and they duck so
they don't shoot back that's a plus plus
I never thought about that one it's okay
so man that burns up that Barrel so I'll
get a new one
yes those first two seconds they're kind
of crucial absolutely if you don't get
fire superiority just kiss your ass
goodbye that's why um
my yard's all wore pith helmets and AKs
and I wore a pith helmet oh is that
right which is kind of goofy it's tall
and skinny as I am with a pith helmet on
but all you needed was that that one
second uh where they they hesitate for a
second what the hell is that and then
bam is he a Russian yeah exactly yeah I
uh I would love to have caught a Russian
I would have made lots of money on those
oh absolutely yeah yeah
did you run into any any other foreign
troops like the Chinese down there or
um you just came up conventional NBA did
also in the NBA recruit some of the
Monte yards that came against you there
I think we had a VC we I think we had a
guy on our team that was uh one of the
bad guys and I never took him to the
field right yeah and the other guys kind
of
nobody I guess he kind of fit in a
little bit but nobody really liked him
that much and and uh but I kept my eye
on him and I just never took him to the
field sure I had my standard group of
guys that I uh that's probably maybe
five six guys that I would you know move
around for different things and
um and my one my one interpreter but he
he quit he got too nervous and he didn't
want to do it anymore so but we didn't
really need in the Tripper because when
you're in the fields it's all hands on
yeah and you know what you're doing and
you know if you're been doing it that
long and you know what you're doing you
don't really need an interpreter but
that's that's also indicative of the
unique side of uh our of the SF men
training working with the indigenous
troops to the high level of Competency
when you're on the ground
there's no talk no need for an
interpreter yeah and uh you're able to
to run a five-man team yep wow I like
that yeah and so as things went on did
the uh the code name for Cambodia was
Daniel Boone
and uh
did the you find the AO situation
changing uh more intense contact and uh
anything like that that came over for
you absolutely it's the 80 90 targets
the the parrots be official carriers
that they always got heavy contact there
and a lot of the operations were and
there was more hilly right because the
other Targets in Cambodia were more flat
mostly yeah but they but the Pirates
speak didn't mean that was just you know
you're going to get shot out I mean so
no kidding yeah you always got in
contact there well we got in contact
everywhere really sure I think the
length of the operations where missions
were
maybe for seven days so maybe yeah well
we were told five we planned for five
but sold them in for five yeah exactly
and uh yeah and so did you plan on uh
picking up water along the way did you
carry the extra canteens did you picked
up water yeah had your purification
pills pills I don't know if that really
worked but I never got
um dysentery as far as I know yeah so
so yeah yeah pick it up on the streams
that we were indeed which was a
dangerous thing to do but yeah well the
team did it one at a time yeah there's a
way to do it the right way in the wrong
way yeah
yeah that's right and we've seen other
people that have done it the wrong way
to pay the price we actually were
filling our canteen to Coffer team
leader ever
was uh filling his canteen down in the
river and we were all and there was a
trail along the river right between two
base camps and that's what we were in
there for to try to find out some
information about the base camp and uh
and I'm you've got guards up and down on
both sides well whatever it's getting
the canteens filled and uh and here
comes a guy walking down the trail
no weapon
just
walking down the trail and I jump out
and uh you know chuhoi I don't know if I
hit him somebody told me I hit him but
anyway the chuhoi and uh uh and uh he
turned him around they tied up his arms
behind him yeah and uh and we took off
you know 90 degrees from there on that
radio guy and I said you know contact
you know and I have a
I don't know what the code was it's a
number of some kind I got a one eight or
whatever it was and the fact says say
that again yeah IMI you know what you
know repeat last transmission so
um and so they launched assets I mean of
course man and um and took us we didn't
even go back to the launch date they
flew us right directly into bammy to it
really yeah and the guy the bad guy
it's a funny story The the guy he
crapped himself on the chopper and uh
and there was another American there and
good good friend of mine Dave Paul
and uh I'm calling him funny because
he's the guy with two first names yeah
yeah and anyway he sat on him because he
didn't want him jumping out or getting
freaked or whatever but he said man you
should
get him off
we got pictures of when we get of course
they hand you the beer and you know and
all that kind of stuff and there's some
pictures from that aren't there yeah
yeah and I'll never forget Troy Gilly
who I I love to death he's one of the
few officers that had a tremendous
amount of respect absolutely you know
but Troy Troy's One of a Kind yeah and
Troy
um uh came up to the guy and put his arm
around his shoulder and he said
something that comforted the guy says
something basically like Hey we're not
going to hurt you man everything is cool
just take it easy and the guy you could
just see the guy just just relax yeah
and uh so we didn't know anything about
it and
the uh
flew him off to Saigon or wherever to be
uh you know interviewed and uh
interrogated and uh ends up that he was
a cook
and he was going from he was a head cook
and he was going from this Camp to that
camp you know short and menus or doing
whatever and um and so everybody came
back and they started laughing man I
gotta cook man
but I got my 200 in in seven days in
Taiwan you got your Seven Days Seven
Days In Time one which it was funny
because two 200 bucks ain't gonna last
long and no r r and so uh I called I got
a hold of my dad yeah back in Canada and
I said man I sure could use some money
could you send me something he sent me a
thousand dollars on um
oh no Western Union Western Union yeah
no kidding
so what was your rank when you got in
Vietnam and when you got to your pow
what was the what was your rank at that
time were you Sergeant I had to go to
play cool to become an E6
and that was a and uh so I I uh so when
you get in country you come right out of
training group I think I went in as a
sergeant didn't we all get there a
sergeant no oh well in my case I got
demoted before I went over so I arrived
as an educe maybe well maybe I did too I
can't remember no well at the training
group a lot of for our people like on
you where you you're the baby SF program
you come in do basic AIT jump school
training group so that's about a year by
the time you're done your MOS is Como So
within a year you're done a month r r
before you deploy and then you go to Nam
when you land there you might be a PFC
for sure maybe an E4 respect for because
that was a Como uh MOS and all of our
guys were e4s eventually yeah I've never
respect it was always the PFC or or
because MOS then you're a sergeant I
just don't not remember being a spec
well you've been so busy well you didn't
have corporals they did but for that MOS
again this is military's talk now yeah I
don't know what I'm talking about guys
know from being a combo geek yeah yeah I
don't remember that's okay so you go to
Taiwan you get your seven days because
there's not many guys we've interviewed
that actually did it
I never went to Taiwan no get your seven
day rfw yeah we all did indeed yeah
and uh of course the the Mike crimmins
got pictures of three Americans
um uh when he was on an operation with
Frank opal and um and they were wearing
berets
what yeah and they uh he mentioned that
on his sit rep and uh and he got
pictures of it and they took the team
out right away at the x-filled the team
put him on a chopper with a camera and
flew him right straight to Saigon
there figure out who the three guys were
never heard yeah never heard Mike never
heard Mike said uh here's the camera
okay thank you son you can see it yeah
wow but if you caught one oh Americans
were
fifteen thousand dollars each I think is
that right yeah the prices and I know
there's a ten thousands for Chinese
right and then for Russian Russians they
were all in that range and then um VC
was 200 bucks yeah but a regular MVA was
probably a thousand or something you
figure you get a bonus for getting a
cook at least you come back cooking a
couple meals for yourself you know
but I'll guarantee that
um when they did that this was a History
Channel show that I did
um uh secrets of the Arsenal it's called
Behind Enemy Lines okay and and uh and
they when they show as they media does
you know oh you can't just get out with
that prisoner without being contact we
got to have a gunfight you know so but I
don't think we've got any contact we met
we ran away we called the x-fill chopper
landed we all the two Choppers because
of the people we had we had one more two
Choppers and flew in straight into bammy
too and I don't think we got any contact
so
that's a nice change oh yeah and so I
think probably because we we knew we
were in two large base camps uh we had
gone into one and they saw they didn't
see us but they heard something and and
so we turned around and ran real quick
because we we have done that a couple of
times because they think you're game you
know dear boar or something right right
and so you know you take off real quick
and he said well that was a close one
sit trap and said well okay let's go and
try this other Camp yeah yeah you know
kind of sneaking around trying to find
stuff and so I'm pretty pretty sure that
after we got that pow and they
interrogated him that day or that night
I bet you they'd be 52 because there was
two large base camps wow you know so and
again your terrain there is pretty flat
no that I think that was fairly flat
yeah and then what kind of canopy was a
single double I don't think it was
Triple yeah it was probably just double
stuff you're able to move a little more
quickly yeah yeah
but not be on the trails exactly yeah
yeah never do Trails never ever do
Trails you know well were you there when
uh no you arrived in 69 at uh
at the CCS that was after February
because my uh my high school quarterback
Hal croskey was on that team and he was
Kia in February of 69. but you got here
just after that just after yeah yeah and
Shriver yeah just after all that and he
was April of 69. yeah and because mad
dog had been up to CCN and Eldon
barger's Recon team went into a base
area that just had stayed behinds he
pushed him out next day Jerry went in
with his Hatchet force and they had 15
helicopters loaded with Intel Maps
rations and that was one of the Jerry's
really major successes yeah and this was
up to CCN go along with everything he
did down south wow yeah in his spare
time he and Klaus were up there with us
good God yeah but uh
so you were there you arrived after
Jerry this was a listed as Kia yes yeah
okay so that probably tightens it I
don't know did I say March or it's April
it was his was April so I got there
right after him right yeah wow yeah
welcome to CCS yeah when you have Ledges
like that going down and then so
lieutenant John Potter was there
can't remember the name yeah okay and so
your team Lieutenant Ash and the ones I
remember Lieutenant Ash and uh and Troy
Gilley of course yeah
yes and then uh Troy was just um
he's one of the Legends too because he's
such a good officer finding good
officers uh people that appreciate what
we're doing on the ground he understood
he was uh Intel I think that's two
I don't know and then he ended up
running Recon did he yeah and state and
Lieutenant actually ended up in fact I
took him uh on his first time Lieutenant
you broke him in yeah the colonel wanted
him to be the team leader
and I said I went and talked to the
colonel just sir
you know at least let him be strap
hanger I mean he's got to at least learn
a little yeah something and he said yeah
okay and so he uh
is that Fred Lindsay then
who was the uh OIC at that point
yeah maybe yeah I know Fred because he
he listened to his men yeah I think so
um I forgot about Fred absolutely yeah I
forgot about him yeah but he's uh still
around yeah it's about 88 89 now and
it's still going strong yeah
um God bless him but he was an officer
that was that cared about the Greek I
know people said I always spoke highly
of him and uh of God who else was it but
but Pete had the highest regards for him
yeah and man Pete was a hard sell for
any officer so Pete signed off you knew
that he was good yeah
and uh so any other missions that come
to mind that stick out for you were the
[__] was in the fan and you're going I'm
not sure if we're going to get back to
Canada or not on this one
um
well uh when copper was killed and I
took over the team's team oh when was
that what happened there
we were heading we were doing a um to
the trail watch and we could hear
machinery and we could hear him doing
some work and it was an open field
and we're walking along the the tree
line heading over to where we could
Overlook where you know sure looked down
see what they were doing
and everybody walked by
this Point everybody walked by and I
looked it was again uh a man a soldier
doing like a what do you call it an LP
an OP you sit there to watch which makes
sense actually because it was on the
tree liner with an open field but he
made another lesson well learned he made
an eye contact
and if I've learned I learned that a
long time ago where
in when I was there is that you cannot
move
you can hunker down and not move and
people walk right by you and don't ever
make eye contact for some reason when
you look at somebody in the eye if
you're hunkered down for some reason
they catch you and he made eye contact
and obviously he hadn't done it with any
of the other guys on the team yeah made
eye contact with me so I lit him up yeah
and um and so
[__] you know I have contact us and
there have to be a B-52 bomb crater
close by which makes a great place to
jump into oh yeah um and so there was
ever we had a third guy a new guy it was
a radio guy born on
um
and
um fact was flying over and he was
firing either smoke or whatever he had
with him and he said you got a bunch of
guys coming in on him coming up the hill
coming in your area
and so we got into a contact just off at
the tree line and uh and all of a sudden
a big explosion and and it just I mean
through it
when I came here you're in the bomb
creator in the bomb creator something
happened like a grenade or something in
the bomb crater and it looked like
meat splayed along a walk you know like
the bomb crater it kind of looks like a
walk sure yeah and everybody's just laid
out around this thing yeah
um I'd gotten shot here I got a shrapnel
in here which cut the artery no which
I'd never seen and blood actually does
spur it squirts it squirts out that's
the first time that I've seen that uh
copper took one right between the eyes
right there on that yeah same explosion
um boiling the radio guy went right
through his knee
um
my one of my yards got it he got in one
cheek and out the other but uh it didn't
hit any teeth
so yeah so I don't either was yelling or
he had his mouth open but it went in one
cheek and out the other
um
and uh
so Coffer was not breathing
so when I finally came to and I so I uh
I stuck my finger in this hole and I you
know I had my car and my other hand well
that doesn't seem to be working you know
and and so I did that and then stopped
the the blood the bleeding yeah and I
went over Coffer and I gave him CPR and
and he started breathing again
got him breathing again
um and so they brought in the Slicks uh
gun ships and um I always love it when
they increase like this gunships and you
know they're out of ammo and the pilot
reaches out with his pistol man yeah and
that's a bad sign that's bad sign
so but uh anyway they dropped rope
ladders and I hate rope ladders but they
drop rope ladders uh for us to get out
so you had enough canopy they couldn't
land yeah and no I don't know why I mean
I would have thought they could yeah but
you know but anyway you're on the ground
you're not yeah I maybe I didn't see
things from that perspective you know
but uh I couldn't obviously take um
Coffer up the the rope ladder so I
stable and snap linked them in on the
rope ladder which made it easier to
climb up sure and so radio got claimed
up
with a hole through his knee he claimed
yeah and adrenaline is a really do
something man but uh and I thought he
carried His Radio with him but he he
apparently no he emptied his car into
the his rock with the radio and all that
um I guess he took the pads with him I
don't know the cactus but anyway so I'm
getting up and this is I was I was
there's more there are a lot of funny
stories that oh yeah that's why we're
here today you know and so climbing the
rope ladder and and if I could finally
get up oh man and I know for some reason
I had buttoned my shirt down I had that
was rolled up and I you didn't put a
bandage or anything on the wound no I
just rolled my thing down like yeah
right down like in both arms sure I I
don't know and I'm getting up a rope
ladder and I get into the chopper and I
do that and I guess the blood had pulled
up somehow in that
my shirt so when I like that all this
blood came out and the prop wash coated
the entire inside of the chopper man the
all the windscreen in front of the
pilots but the thing that was funny is
it coated the door Gunners Plexiglas
thing yeah yeah anything like that and
it just
and barfed all over his mic and I for
somehow I know I shouldn't but somehow
that was just funny for me I just
thought that was funny oh yeah and hear
your story today it's funny yeah so we
we went back to um
it was the Southern Southern launch site
so we went back into uh um a quan Loy
and Conference died that night
uh Sue went off to the one of the
um yard one of the Vietnamese Hospital
right and uh and they took care they
just bandaged this up and uh you know I
see I didn't get the shrapnel out no
it's still there no yeah when they were
doing a something uh I took an x-ray
for this arm for something uh and uh and
it's not a big metal it's just a real
teeny little piece just enough to make
you bleed a lot yeah you know so well
thank God it wasn't too big because your
finger could have worked if it was too
big so anyway it's still there yeah
like but I went to see the
um the yards didn't get a lot of respect
from the Vietnamese as you know oh and
especially if it was a Vietnamese
hospital I was worried about him so
quite rightly yeah and I went down to
that hospital and made sure that he had
what he needed to have and that he was
good you know and then also made sure
his family was taken care of making sure
they got his paychecks and that kind of
stuff and uh
kit the kit was the one that was shot
through the cheeks and he was there for
a week or two when he came home and uh
just another day another damn fog
Paradise yeah
so uh so what did you see in terms of
escalated uh efforts against the Recon
teams or the AO toughening up
uh
uh I guess they're all they were always
tough I never really noticed things I
mean it got worse and worse because uh
or Worse the worse you know especially
down in the 80 90 series yeah now when
you say 80 90 I think of the triple
um the Paris Peak area facial carries
and
um and I think what we a lot of stuff
but kind of weird a lot of the stuff
they wanted us to take soil samples and
always yeah tree
vegetation vegetation and stuff and all
this stuff prior to the invasion
oh because that's the thing you know I
can't remember where they invaded But I
think it was in that parrots big area oh
is that right but I'm not sure yeah
somebody'd have to correct me on that
one right so what was the difference
because
um Paris Peak and then the other area
what was the difference between the two
I didn't I don't think that in both hot
targets bad yeah bad bad targets the
same to the ones up north there's bad
targets some might be a little easier
than others but they don't need you to
go in the easy ones no yeah
and I can't remember
some some areas were flat but I didn't
really do too much on the flat areas I
mean that was nice uh on the flat ones
because it made it a lot easier but it's
just the ones that I hated when you go
to hunt oh and you're climbing by
grabbing the uh some branches or the
base of a small twig to try to pull you
oh
that's just in each of the Top Welcome
to the Jungle baby yeah yeah get to the
top I just fall back okay I get to take
a break man so uh in April 70 I went
home April 70 you could have gone home
but you said uh I think I'll hang around
just a little longer yep so when your D
Rose came up
what happened because it's because a lot
of people don't realize a lot of our
guys extended
um we well here's a funny story so
um you can you can re-up I found out for
uh six months and you get a cash you get
30 days leave anywhere in the world
and a bunch of money I can't remember
how much yeah but I can't remember it
was a good hunk of money oh yeah
absolutely back in those days yeah and
um and so so me being the Hustler I was
always the the scrounger you know hey
hey guys you know why don't we get us
airline tickets at the most expensive
airline tickets we can get from uh
Saigon yeah Seattle Tacoma or whatever
yeah oh back there okay you know from
from uh Fort Lewis area whatever that
civilian airport is and I said it's I'm
doing some research and however I was
doing that and I found the most
expensive ticket goes from
Seattle Tacoma to Tierra del Fuego the
southern tip of South America
and I said no what we ought to do is
five or six of us all did we all
re-upped
one two three four five there's five of
us oh really who are the other Cocos
beard is here my cremins okay another
Canadian yeah uh Frank opal
and nimsy and Pletcher no okay and so um
and so we get we get to the airport
psych man we're gonna turn it in for
cash and then you'll go and do whatever
you want and uh so we get there and we
said uh I'm gonna just want to turn
these in we don't really want to go to
Dear del Fuego we just want the cash and
she goes uh I'm sorry but those are
military issue tickets I can't do that
oh no and the Hustler gets hanged oh man
I said you kind of thinking to myself oh
they're gonna kill me man I said you
know I mean like what are you gonna do
spend your 30 days with penguins man I
said oh this is gonna be a killer so
they um I said well you got to do
something she said but I'll tell you
what I can do then I'll I'll uh I'll
exchange them for other tickets I can't
give you any cash but I'll let you fly
somewhere and which is probably about
the same I guess too bad the cat would
have been nice but so anyway I went home
to Canada Mike went home to Canada
Frank went to Miami where he bought some
property and uh and Fletcher nimsy went
to uh Copenhagen
oh wow it's been 30 days we know why
they went there yeah man indeed
[Laughter]
so you take your 30 days you come
bouncing back pick up uh right where you
left off with the RT pick yeah I went
home
I re-upped but I had just been wounded
wounded again uh no this is when I got
wounded in the face
I just got yeah I was just getting
better from being wounded in the face
from the car yeah okay
um from them hitting the front sight yes
sir right and uh and so when I landed
my mom and dad were at the airport and
[Music]
um
we you know we all got home but they got
the family doctor came over and he
wanted to do X-rays and check me out and
and that's when he did X-rays and he
said man we're lucky because it didn't
get my eyes oh yeah like from here on
down and he said it's just a you know
not superficial but and nothing no big
deal
wow yeah it ain't fatal and no big deal
yeah indeed you don't mind carrying
looks for metal around that's it oh my
God so you know it stayed my uh 30 days
there with the mom and dad and then um
and then Mike drove down from where he
lived it was not too far from me and
then we drove back uh
I guess we I can't remember where we
went
I guess we just went to Buffalo
or that another time I can't remember
anyway they flew us back to Fort Lewis
and back to RT pick indeed yeah so by
then you come back the AO is toughening
up a little bit and uh any particular
missions that come to mind when you
return for essentially a second tour
Duty well it's one that everybody talks
about I know they were going to want me
to talk about it tomorrow indeed let's
get a preview
Frank opal was the other team I ran with
yes sir with Team all
gotta fix out that one in August and uh
he and I were playing Chinese Checkers
in my Hooch and I could tell something
was wrong he was down and he goes uh
what's the matter Frank because I just I
got this operation I want to go on and
and my 1-1 I'll say his name but my one
one doesn't want to go with me doesn't
want to do it and were had been imbibing
a little bit of course oh yeah and Frank
has his famous drink of scotch and root
beer root beer and uh and I'm doing
whatever I'm drinking and uh and uh I
said oh I said don't worry about a Frank
[__] I'll go with you yeah and he says
yeah yeah I'll go with you man no like
hey it's your move let's go and so the
next day
I've got a picture of them that Jason
has
um because I gave them all of my
pictures
um there's so Classics in there yeah and
he
he was coming from the talk back to me
and he's got his floppy hat on that he
always wore he's got a grease gun for
some reason he always loved to carry in
that damn grease gun that was his weapon
of choice really and he had his trench
knife out one of those brass knuckles
with the bladens like this and he's he's
looking at me and give him a big grin on
his face and I go what's what's going on
he said well we're on man that's yeah oh
what he says yeah that operation you
said you'd go with me yeah yeah well
we're going I said oh all right what are
we doing uh well we're gonna parachute
in
what
he said we're gonna we're gonna do a
jump
I said well okay
um and his little people were trained up
to jump uh probably but not probably not
but these were his team were Chinese
nuns oh and I mean he had a whole team
of Charlie was it Charlie Chan or Jackie
Chan's yes a whole bunch of Jackie Chan
these tough little guys oh they're good
um and so they gave us uniform helmets
the only difference was we had a like a
smoke jumper helmet it was like a
football helmet with a big wire cage
right and uh and so they roped up the uh
20th SOS one of their Huey's because
they had you know navigating at night
yeah and so they roped it up so we're
gonna do a night jump but we're gonna do
a practice jump so we're gonna go down
to uh probably long time yeah and uh and
jump into long time so these guys can
practice their uh navigating so okay
that's cool so and I can't remember
whether they had a green light or
somebody just said go or whatever but
you know anyway uh word got out go so we
all rolled out of the chopper and uh and
everything went fine and landed and
we're Gathering up our gear and then all
of a sudden the whole
the the whole field that we landed in
lit up with floodlights and and what the
hell and uh Frank said they put your
weapon down and put your arms up
and so we did well did this we had
landed in a front of a Korean military
base
and these are the Rocks rocked oh yeah
stuff I'm surprised they didn't shoot
but we put our arms up and uh stayed
that way a Jeep gate opened and a Jeep
eventually came out uh we got loaded up
in a Jeep or two Jeep or whatever took
us back into talk Frank it's on the
phone
and uh to to someone and saying this is
your practice job that was our practice
yeah in a site in Saigon and they came
and picked us up took us to house 10 and
then probably and then brought a film on
there yeah it was a safe house in Saigon
for uh SOG yeah and these spook and
spooky slum there a little bit once in a
while
so we get back and we're gonna do a jump
now uh yeah we don't not even so
qualified we don't need to practice jump
anymore let's just go do it yeah you
know so what was the mission do you want
to jump into
don't know what I can't remember what
the mission was yeah because you're a
strap hanging with your buddy yeah yeah
and uh and so but I'm the one one yeah
you know there were just the two of us
and three nungs and so we land we
parachute out at night I gave some 30
miles in Cambodia yeah damn Nung broke
his ankle no yeah so so we hunkered down
um because I was wondering what the hell
we gonna do with the geared it's like in
the movies do you bury it or like yeah
they're parachute and riggers and
everything and you had an emergency
shoot too no no no it's a big award not
an award the certificate that I got here
at Bragg when they took all of us guys
yeah done combat jumps uh 500 feet above
ground level car 15 no Reserve uh
sterile shoot sterile equipment no
kidding 500 feet 500 feet and I've heard
somebody say that they did it at 400
feet but 500 feet is what our
um certificate says you barely have time
to get your shoe open and let alone do a
PLS out of a chopper yeah because the
prop bar is going to give you a little
extra downward encouragement there you
think so anyway we um we hunkered down
for the night and they came and picked
up the the uh his known and all the gear
and throw it in a chopper so we have
just a regular it might have been
parachuted in but it was just and but
it's still the first one oh yeah you
know but it was just all compromised so
and we didn't stay very long either uh I
remember we were only there
uh one night maybe maybe two at the most
but we got shot out of that one and they
pulled us out wow so that's with the
broken ankle no well they came in and
took him out oh is that right yeah they
came in the next morning picked up all
the gear and the Nung so basically it's
a compromise just like a regular
insertion yeah you know we had jumped in
but they had to come in and pick the
Nung up because so then you continue all
with the four-man team yes or did you
replace no four Mana kept on with the
four-man how long you able to stay on
the ground like I said maybe about two
only about two days we weren't very long
from that one
I didn't
I guess with sometimes when Coffer was
running it we'd end up having to be a
little bit longer we could maybe last
around for four or five days uh in fact
I've probably done a four or five day
too but not very very seldom usually
it's just a one or two day thing you're
in because at some point they they learn
that you're there yeah through rdf other
compromise or somebody told them that we
were coming you know that's always that
rumors there oh yeah you know well you
know in John plaster's pectoral book
near the end there's a picture of Speedy
Gas Bar with the NVA spy
ah and at because Speedy didn't know at
the time but after the war ended in
April 30 1975 the Spy received the
highest award that North Vietnam gave to
its spies I didn't know that he was
there with Speedy Gaspard and SOG
headquarters I'll be absolutely and uh
of course they had Trail Watchers yeah
and they had you know oh bunkers I mean
you heard Mike Taylor yesterday was
which by the way you and I are here
together today as part of the third
Special Forces Group
SOG Heritage week and it's a SOG
Symposium where more than 20 sagmens
come together and this is uh November
the 9th today
uh 2021 just for the record and uh we're
here to get a chance to finally meet
each other I heard so much about you and
your legendary exploits and ccs and so
we're finally able to connect today but
um while you're here they're talking
about that combat jump is you'll be one
of the guest speakers today or tomorrow
I think he said they've got other
speakers for the day so he said he wants
to talk to me about the
silver pistol the combat jump and the
bow and arrow yeah so well let's let's
go to the bow and arrow before we go to
the silver pistol because the silver
pistol I'll tell you something that's
funny I didn't know what the word
Symposium what what does Symposium mean
it's a gathering for an official
Gathering to learn share because it's a
gathering officially yes Google it okay
yep that is the first definitely you
know what the second definition is what
a drinking party no yeah I'll drink to
that try that man see you would know
that and that's something something
too funny yeah that is funny yeah the um
we had spent
the biggest thing we could do is catch a
pow
you're ready for another r r you didn't
have one we have we have our priorities
yeah but they wanted the Intel I didn't
give a [__] about the Intel I want my
money on another RNR yeah you know
um and so uh we tried different
different kind of different ways you
know how you do it setting up Ambush and
stuff how many different ones did you
try try two okay
um the the one I tried I'll mention this
tomorrow is I took a claymore and I
peeled the front off a claymore with all
the pellets right so all I had was the
C4 right and then I took a plastic bag
full of the Cs powder and I packed the
whole thing with cs powder so that now
that would stun some money for a second
or two for you to go jump on it yeah
right when you think yeah and so
um
coming down the trail and uh and you're
in the Airbus position they're coming
down the trail now how many is they only
two ooh it was perfect that was perfect
yeah you know and they had their weapons
flown nice you're looking like that so
oh this is gonna be perfect
firing the Claymore
wasn't really expecting that kind of a
blast but it had blown it blew the it
was so concussive it blew the powder
over these guys didn't even bother them
yeah that's what they turn around and of
course on and started firing we all
started firing and we took off and got
pulled up so that was uh that was one of
our but see that's trying to catch the
pow of course so okay uh we could
probably have figured that out but I had
a longbow with me yes this is what I we
were trying to get around to here I had
a longbow with me on one Mission you
just wait wait so were you drinking at
night to say maybe tomorrow I'll take a
long bow and arrow with me to the
mission in Cambodia yeah okay a whole
bunch of arrows yeah
so and so uh but I was practicing with
the I'd play with the yards we sure they
had their crossbows and we were shooting
a little cardboard milk containers and
you know and I'd use the Longbow yeah uh
Graham number one same same Cinema you
know yeah very cool yeah and um and I
said well let's take the let's take the
the sun if weapons aren't silenced no
you know there's a subsonic just still a
little metallic Clark and all that kind
of stuff the only silence one is those
beautiful little Browning 22s mm-hmm
I wish I'd stolen one
but uh anyway too much of Boy Scout
ideas indeed so anyway we figured let's
take the uh let's let's take the bowl
and we'll take the bowl it was a heavy
team
um actually with Lieutenant Ash's first
operation I had um Frank opal went with
me okay Mike crimmins you're the one
zero I'm the one zero my cremins was my
one one uh and then I've got Lieutenant
Ash and uh opal and a guy named Boylan
so that's a lot of Americans oh yeah
like five Americans and three yards so
you had gone into S3 and said I got an
idea we had a good drink last night I
want to do this and give me some more
Americans and yeah and you went forward
they let us do anything yeah they pretty
well let us do anything within reason
but they could do any of that stuff okay
so now you're on the ground with six men
with your Longbow yeah did they say
crossbows or anything no back yeah no no
no no no just animal guns enamel guns
enamel yeah and uh but I did have my uh
uh vest yes with my um and I didn't have
my m79 with me but I did have my vest
for Rounds because for for lieutenant
Ash okay I'm 79 yeah and um and so we
land and uh when we're moving off the um
the uh the LZ and there's bunkers
whoa yes it will and so we got in
contact with him from the bunkers we're
firing back
this is not working so uh bad decision
Rob so go back to another uh bomb crater
yeah perfect and uh and so lots of
firing going on back and forth
and uh and I I actually fired the use
the bow
and fired three or four hours at it and
jumped up and screamed and did all that
kind of stuff and true story and not
bullshitting they broke contact they
stopped shooting at us no yep they
stopped shooting at us and we all kind
of looked at us and choppers then
arrived and you know shot the place up
and whatnot and landed and everybody got
pulled out and nobody was hurt so did
you get any enemy with your boat you're
aware of well I think so but you know if
if I did
if I did I'm sure they got a American
Legion in North Vietnam somehow you know
like their own version yeah and there's
a guy saying you ain't gonna believe
this one
oh yeah so I don't know but but you know
I jumped up I fired I think I might even
left the bunker
um moving towards them uh I think that's
what the award says I really can't
remember but I don't think I did but
anyway this is your award that you
received the award for Valor was for
that for that whole operation yeah but
the award was a bra star Silver Star
with Valor yeah yeah five of those five
yeah how many purple hearts two two yeah
I didn't get one for this it cracked a
rib but no blood so yeah no blood so
yeah blood stays on the inside rule
number one
yeah
a couple basic rules you know so anyway
that that it was a [__] thing
um
yeah that's that's part of your Legend
Rob well it's one of the reasons why not
first of all I don't know many one zeros
or let anybody facade that actually goes
into the AO
with a bow and arrow thank you I'm sorry
but we're officially on record with that
yeah yes sir well
I think it's one of the reasons why
not me but we were all at that
the men that I ran with were all 18 19
year old kids yeah you know I mean
they'll do anything hard charging and we
all went through the same
psych test to get into SF right and so
we all think exactly this we're all
different shapes but we're all the same
up inside yeah so we're all a little bit
bent indeed everybody's willing to carry
that bow kind of thing you know and uh
and I think that's the thinking changed
with SF and that's why now you'll see
because I do some of that point sitting
for the compass course yes and uh I've
done it twice along with Jack Tobin yeah
Jack doesn't know all he does everyone
Colonel Tobin's out there hardcore that
one oh yeah but um I hope he's feeling
he's not feeling well lately but I hope
he's okay he came to that he came to the
SFA Reunion yeah he and Bessie were
there he's all dot up in the tuxedo of
course Betsy looks yeah she's a
wonderful gal yeah yeah he was supposed
to supposed to be with him this weekend
and he he couldn't come to our little
get-together because he was sick he
sounded real bad oh is that right yeah
this is on Saturday we better do a comma
check when we get done
so um anyway I think SF I talked to
Chris Crane and he said nowadays I've
noticed the SF guys are older
when they come in going through the
selection they're more mature
um they're all in their mid to late 20s
they've all had a couple of
um down range even x-rays yeah and then
even the kids I call the the high school
or the call it in the high school yeah
they can come right out so I was talking
a couple of them and they seem to be
pretty squared away they are you know
today's Green Beret is just amazing oh
the athletes I mean just you know it's
no longer like it was when we were in
when I was in indeed you know it's just
and I when I was in I did a lot of work
in in Baghdad security work at the
embassies and stuff like that and uh
that's one of the things I've noticed
that I've mentioned it to everybody that
American Military nowadays even the the
truck driver back in the day the truck
drivers with us weren't they couldn't
they look like Cooks you know well these
guys everybody in the Army nowadays is
100 professional oh yeah and I'm just
impressed as hell with the military but
um nrsf troops particular so yeah um as
we're heading down to wind up Trail here
talk to us about the silver pistol a
little bit because you earned it and
well
it's it's kind of strange it's nothing
big deal about it you know yes it is
well you're being humble Rob here no
because I talked to pla you talk to
plaster and I said well how many
and I think they made 50. think this is
what he was saying I think they made 50
and they actually gave out 19 to SF the
rest of them probably went to the
generals and Colonels and so
I don't know how many people got them
let's see he said 19. I know there are
maybe five
at CCS Scotland
Fletcher opal got one liberty got one
we're talking to brownie nine millimeter
silver yeah that Chrome plated one right
it's in a nice little mahogany box with
velvet and they gave it to to SOG Recon
guys at the end of your tour Duty yeah
as as an exemplary service thank you sir
here's something for you to take home
show your grandchildren someday yeah
so I I still have it I another funny
story so I took it I took it back to
Canada yeah and I've got all the
documentation and paperwork or trophy
authorized authorized to travel within a
and of course it was a lot easier back
then
get on the helicopter and I'm in on the
airplane and the pilot told the pilot no
so just let me have it in the cockpit
and I said yes that's cool get off in
Toronto my mom and dad are there I don't
even mention anything to them I can see
in my duffel bag or in my whatever it is
get back to the house and I show and I'm
showing my dad I'm a dad look at what
they gave me all right all right pretty
cool he said uh he said I think you know
what I ought to do is is I ought to take
it over to the police station my dad at
this point was a federal was a judge oh
so I'm going to take it to the police
station and they'll put it in their
Armory and uh because listen for
safekeeping and I said okay
and uh and so yeah 10 years later
whenever I can't remember but I wanted I
had but I kept the Box
so the Box kept I I had I couldn't come
back into the U.S by the way uh once I
was in Canada they wouldn't let me come
back in unless I got another green card
no I was still I was a Canadian citizen
I know isn't that something after all
that time after 18 months of serving our
country and and couldn't come back it's
a little border patrol yeah so um and I
had been deported several times
um because it can't hitchhike if you
hitchhike they take it back to the
border and you got to sign papers and
all that crap when I was younger anyway
so I got the I got this mahogany I got
this box and I got to get my pistol back
so my my dad went to the police
department got the pistol Out and
because I went to atnf and they said no
it's a war Surplus weapon is not allowed
and I appealed it and appealed it and I
kept getting nope nope nope you can't
bring it back unless you weld it
will it slide and put lid in the barrel
or something like that oh my gosh which
I'm not going to do of course so I
waited until my wife was coming across
the border with her baby with a diaper
bag when I shoved it in the diaper bag
wow brought it over in the diaper bag
and
I got it back wow now I got it well
we're at that point where our schedule
is getting a little tight here or nearly
we go on a little bit longer but we're
on a tight schedule so any final
thoughts on terms of your service at ccs
and which was uh of Legend the bow and
arrow and your commanders were impressed
enough to give you that Silver
Browning nine millimeter so yeah any any
final thoughts no no thank you well it's
my pleasure and uh we're at that point
where um
today uh thanks to Jocko podcast we were
able to have this production and bring
it to our viewers and we thank all the
service members today in our country the
border patrol First Responders and even
the parents who are fighting for freedom
in America these days and we also uh
thank the men and women who served our
country in the years past as Heroes men
like Rob Graham who came from Canada to
serve our country with great Valor and
distinction and we also remember and
salute the men and women who aren't here
today who remain missing an accident
again we thank Jocko Productions and
thank you for coming Rob until next time
thanks for having me God Bless America
you said it Airborne airborne
well welcome welcome back and thank you
again for sitting here for our little
post uh sogcast analysis and once again
you're sitting here listening to one of
our CCS Legends Rob Graham I've heard
about him I even heard about him in
Vietnam but never met him and I'd gone
through training group with Gary Graham
who went who was NSF he went to Vietnam
but I never knew what happened to Gary
but heard about Robin so
anyways here we are so your oppression
sir what a what a character uh it was an
absolute pleasure to meet and listen to
uh Rob's stories and
um the bow and arrow can you get over
there I've never in my life you know
there's there's Marine Corps lore where
you know uh
Sergeant such and such you know took a
guy out with an e-tool right or you know
there's all this like Legend uh and you
know I've never heard of a bow and arrow
being taken on an OP let alone on a SOG
Mission into Cambodia and then the
five-man team been in the middle of a
firefight next to a bunker standing up
and firing arrows at the enemy oh my God
and then he screamed and the enemy
stopped Legend absolutely that's another
first yeah I've never heard of anything
like that ever anywhere ever incredible
incredible stories though um
and uh you know the lessons he learned
along the way the little things you pick
up you know yeah that stuff's so
important and uh to his point when it's
when it's life or death that sticks with
you and you learn to tuck away your uh
radio antenna yeah because if people are
going to Ambush you wish they shouldn't
Ambush if they are they're gonna wait
for the comma guy to come by yeah yeah
and twice two car 15s gosh I mean in in
the for Not only was uh Rob lucky not to
have shrapnel hit above the nose but if
that round doesn't hit the front sight
it hit it hits him he's going to get him
direct yeah I mean gosh how how
what what are the centimeters between
that round not hitting the front sight
and gosh that's terrible how he took
shrapnel the way he did
um and missed his eyes and it missed his
eyes thank god
um and and it missed him directly thank
God yeah right
incredible yeah incredible just
and then yeah and then his jump
um you know uh the the jump story was
incredible and then the um the uh bomb
damage assessment story that's pretty
wild they insert him before the Box
before the bombs
other I've never heard that before yeah
oh my God the bee on the ground because
we've had big bombs where you do get
knocked off you know it's like yeah and
I mean you can lift it off the ground
and it's just oh my God but to be there
when the Arc Light hits
in correction until I don't know what
that's like no okay no no I don't know
what it's like to be a click from a
massive bomb well I don't either I've
never been on the ground with an
artifact landed so and thankfully I
don't want to be didn't want to be and
to come to poor guy was dozing off yeah
you come to off the ground from the
concussion of a massive bomb Oh my I
can't imagine oh well I'm glad we were
able to fit him in and uh you too sir
that's one of our uh major song legends
that came out of ccs and uh to wrap up
the day here on our visit we're gonna
get back to the uh SOG Heritage week
here at Fort Bragg and third Special
Forces Group and we thank them for
moving forward with that at this time
any final thoughts on uh Rob Graham the
first the one and the only just an
incredible uh honor and pleasure to meet
Robin to to hear some of his uh very
humble you know stories but just massive
exploits to a guy because a few years
back I re I reread one of John plaster's
books and look at the pictures this is
the pictures he's talking about I
remember the president I got to meet
this guy at The Reunion yeah and so I
tried to find him and we just never
connected at the reunions over the years
and so finally here we are
and uh last night we got introduced and
here we are bringing them out for our
our sogcast number 20. so glad we got to
capture those stories from from you guys
oh well thank you for being a part of
that we appreciate it we as always we
thank Jocko willing Productions yes sir
and his right hand man Echo Charles yes
sir and with that we will close out and
as always once again we thank all of our
military today to keep our country safe
our First Responders all the law
enforcement that are out there
particularly in communities where there
is an effort to defund police at a time
when the crime rate's going up here in
2021 we need cops on the streets not
being defunded and we also want to thank
the men and women who served our country
in the past
the people like Rob Graham and for as
always we salute those that are still
missing in action today
and we thank Jocko willink Productions
and we will be back another day for
number 21. thank you again thank you sir
Airborne all the way
okay